we still have lots to go here on this
program but we pause it for the moment
uh to say hello once again to our friend
who joins us on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line getting set to host his
seventh season of america's funniest
videos which returns sunday um on abc at
7 eastern time for its 32nd season
alfonso robero back here on the show how
you doing bud
i'm good my man good to be back with you
good to have you on this program
good to have you
how's it how's the golf game how's the
golf game outstanding right
you know i i i actually about a couple
weeks ago i shot my career low at uh
lakeside because i shot 65 which was
quite amazing
um
but you know yesterday and then i had
been out the work and couldn't play for
like two weeks so then i went out and
shot 75 yesterday so
i mean i mean imagine being mad about it
and here i was i shot a 42 on the back
the other day and i'm like feeling great
about myself yeah that that you should
thank you alfonso yeah but if alfonso if
you did that you'd quit golf
no that happens it happens every once in
a while
and it hurts a little bit but you know
like
rich here's the deal yes i have a lot
more time than you do
you work harder than me
i appreciate you saying that how is
tahoe speaking of that how was tahoe
tahoe was a massive disappointment for
myself but it was always it's always fun
um
now you walk in the door a second you
walk into tahoe thinking you can win it
right alfonso you know i won't say that
i think i could win it but i definitely
feel like i have a top five ending
right like i i go there with the idea in
my mind saying if i play my game this
week top five is absolutely what i can
do and then like it doesn't happen every
year i don't know what it is about that
golf course
but that golf course gets me every year
because it's like you make one mistake
and it's two shots
well how do you do how do you do on that
on the famed par three right near the
lake where uh sean payton wants it off
of someone's boat
i play that whole well every time
because it's like a it's an easy nine
iron or pitching wedge and like
i always make par birdie on that whole i
don't think i i think maybe i've bogeyed
that hole in the last 12 years twice
so who'd you hang with give me give me
some good stuff was you were you around
rogers because that was that was at the
height of the was rogers coming back or
not he was around there at the time i
mean it just was another i didn't see
him much i saw him one time in the
little hospitality tent right you know
said hello because we've played together
a couple times but um yeah he was kind
of staying away from everything uh you
know which i understand obviously he was
going through that that in the middle of
it all of the time um but i spent some
time with timberlake and his kid was
having a um a a birthday party
uh his first birthday so we you know
went and hung out at the house and did
that and uh funny part of that you know
i might be talking too much but they had
a bear scare that week
where a bear actually got into their
rental house get out of here
yeah really and there's video to prove
it
whoa
wow was it justin fields and then during
the party
they had an earthquake
come on
bear in the
you look it up you'll see that tahoe
that they had an earthquake
on like the friday
we did a thursday or friday um middle of
the afternoon there was a big earthquake
like a 4.5 or something like that
and we were all in the house and it was
one of those
great moments where everybody goes let's
go get out
grabbing kids grabbing people out the
house that might be like a the bear in
the house might be uh certainly if
everything is fine uh a submission for
america's funniest videos alfonso well
it's uh it's certainly you know what i
might have to call them and get that
video get it get it from the timberlakes
go for it uh alfonzo ribeiro here on the
rich eisen show and then how you know we
didn't discuss it this week pretty much
because we have been in the tom brady
returns to foxborough wormhole quite a
bit yeah but we hardly even discussed on
this show the ryder cup boat race that
happened at whistling straits that was
unbelievable i mean the whole crew just
came together and
crushed it that was unbelievable you
know
i gotta tell you i think captain steve
stricker did an amazing job
yes he had the horses to run with like
you can't deny that this team was
probably the highest rated team in
history right that i mean
almost all of those guys made it to
uh the the tour championship right at
east lake i mean they had an incredible
team
but there was also a lot of drama going
in with the brooks and and and bryson
deal and which i think the media
obviously like went way too big on uh
made way too much of it especially the
gulf media
but you know
they came together as a team and
supported each other as a team and of
course that alone doesn't make good golf
but he allowed everybody to be
themselves individually while still
being a team and i think that is the
that is the mark of a great leader like
i'm not going to tell you how to prepare
i'ma let you prepare the way you need to
prepare as long as you're prepared
and they seem to have like this
i'm assuming this is it like you know
obviously someone's going to play their
way into the team in the future but
whoever is on this team i think should
get get a spot the next time they really
have what it takes like whatever it is
i mean no questions
you could you could you could always
you know put some
you know other guys on that team that i
think would have still also worked out i
think kevin nod jason kochrack two guys
that could have been on that team and
would have absolutely gelled perfectly
in that team i think kokrak was
like even though kevin nam might have a
higher ranking i think koprak
actually would have been better on that
team than nah because of his distance
off the team
but really what i loved about what
stricker did was courses for courses
the guy that he picked his captain's
picks were all guys who could vomit long
enough on that golf course that the
course couldn't win as easily especially
with the win that they were having right
and by the way i love that that idea of
saying this is the type of golf course
we have to play and whose game works on
that golf course guys like colin
moricara who don't hit it very far but
boy does he have a great game his game
is going to travel everywhere
right which is why i think strickler
made a great choice of putting him and
dustin johnson together because dustin
is going to bomb it so you'd have it on
alternate shot or you he can go for
trying to make birdies and eagles and
all the rest while colin was being
absolutely
you know consistent um
because i would probably say colin was
probably the shortest hitter on that
team but here's a guy with two majors
and then the guy who crushed it maybe
more than anyone else was fenal i mean
what a weekend he had in the ryder cup
like i said whoever was on this team
gets first
crack at the next one i would have to
say and then i just love this and you
know and then we'll talk about your your
show
um what mickelson's turning into like i
love him with the the the that george
hamilton tan
and the biden's sunglasses
and the thumbs up stuff and he's just
out there like living his best like the
la vida loca for him he's got that pga
championship he's got them all in the
case right like now
i just uh
you know he's out there part that part
of the staff him and obviously you know
dl3 there and furyk and fred and the
whole it was just
the whole thing was just great but phil
has just got like this
this aura about him now
the i i can't get enough of it i just
love everybody else
is that what i loved about phil
this
last week was the fact that he was
capable
of riding in the back seat
it wasn't the phil show yeah it was
those guys
but phil was there to help
them in any way he could
which is typically not the case for phil
you know phil white still likes to be at
the front of the table right even he's
the head of the table kind of guy and it
was great to see him take it off of
himself and put it on those 12 guys and
let them be the stars of that show um it
would have been interesting for me to
see tiger and phil
in their roles
could tiger have done that also and i
think tiger is going to become a great
captain and i think he will win
plenty of presidents and ryder cups as a
captain um because i think he's learned
that finally that you know and it's not
really even his fault when he walks into
the room it's like the goats in the
house and you can't deny it right
but he's learned to let these guys kind
of
stand up and be on their own pedestal
while he's allowed to
be which is part of someone who's truly
confident and someone who is truly great
so uh before i get let you go let's talk
about uh afv man uh america's funniest
videos coming up season seven for you
season 32 for the franchise
and i guess there's no reinventing the
wheel right i mean like people submit
videos they're hilarious it shows people
being people and then you just uh guide
us through the whole process unless
there's something new you go for it you
know there's always something a little
new okay but it's the same old thing
we're gonna we're gonna show you funny
funny funny videos
that work for every generation whether
it's your grandparents your grandkids
can sit there together on a sunday night
and watch
some really funny videos this year we
added a little segment that we're doing
oh great it's called what would
alfonso's mom say
and
you know my mom's from trinidad and
tobago so she's got the whole accent and
i actually do her voice
right over the videos okay but we we
talk to my mom we show her the videos
and like mom what would you say to this
like what do you see here that's wrong
and her you know she's very very
straightforward and she'll be like
why would this man go on the roof
there's no reason for you to fall on the
roof you pay somebody to go on the roof
and fix your room now you're gonna go up
the roof you done fell on your bum
yes
but like watching the videos with me
doing her voice and these are the things
that she would say and it's a funny
little segment that obviously rings you
know some laughter and a smile for me
because i get to have a little bit of
fun with my mom so if my mom did it it
would be what's the matter with this
idiot he's going to break his neck like
literally that right
we
that's awesome i love that i shouldn't
say that nothing's new of course
something's new i i just love the
production i love all of it it's just
it's unbreakable man it's been something
i've been watching forever and you're
great at it
thank you very much and yeah about and
also it's the 700th episode
on sunday night
wow that'll be great
you know you i gotta always send out
love to bob saget and tom bergeron
because at the end of the day you know
getting the 700 episodes that is an
awful lot of them and a little bit of me
and um my goal is to continue going you
know get 800 900 and try to make it to a
thousand and uh we we i'm so fortunate
and lucky to be able to do this show and
um you know look we love making people
laugh and if we can continue to do that
there's no reason why this can't keep
going on alfonso great chatting with you
i'll see you soon always fun thanks for
the thanks for the call you take care of
yourself
absolutely be well brother you bet same
to you alfonso roberto fresh office 65
that he follows it with a 75 much to his
dismay
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here